For fans of the Pokémon series, Detective
Pikachu is filled with plenty of playful nods
to the wider Pokémon universe.
But some of these small references are all-too
easy to miss.
To help you keep track, here are a few of
the finer details that may have snuck past
you.
"Whoever you are, I know how to use this."
In the film, we learn that the menacing Pokémon
known as Mewtwo was captured before the events
of Detective Pikachu - and it was able to
escape human captivity 20 years prior to the
events in the film.
This is likely an allusion to the first Pokémon
film, appropriately titled Pokemon: The First
Movie, which made its North American premiere
in November of 1999.
The First Movie centers around Mewtwo's origin
story, beginning with its creation in a lab
on New Island.
Eventually, Mewtwo escapes and subsequently
destroys the entire lab in his rage, but by
the end of the film, it's shown that not all
humans are bad.
Though Detective Pikachu doesn't focus primarily
on Mewtwo and its origin, the parallels are
clear.
Mewtwo is similarly captured, experimented
on, and subsequently escapes in the film,
though it comes to believe that humans aren't
inherently evil.
"Hey what's that?"
"Isn't that a Jigglypuff?"
“JIGGLY!”
"You're right, Brock, it's a Jigglypuff!”
Throughout the Pokémon universe, Jigglypuff
is known for its ability to lull people and
other Pokémon to sleep when it sings.
In the animated series, Jigglypuff's singing
is often used as a joke that inconveniences
the main characters and makes them fear this
balloon-like Pokémon whenever it appears.
In several episodes, the Pokémon performs
for the main characters, only for them to
inevitably fall asleep.
Upset that no one listens to its song, Jigglypuff
becomes angry and draws ridiculous images
on the faces of its sleeping audience.
Jigglypuff makes a brief appearance in Detective
Pikachu.
When Tim and Pikachu visit a cafe, you get
to see a Jigglypuff sing to another patron
as he sleeps on the table.
Just as in the anime, Jigglypuff puffs up,
visibly upset that its song is being ignored.
Unown are unique Pokémon that resemble the
Latin alphabet.
"This Unown feels really hot."
The Pokémon species has 28 total different
forms, and with so many different variations,
it's not surprising that at least one would
make it into the film.
While an actual Unown never makes an appearance
in Detective Pikachu, they do pop up on Tim's
T-shirts as a loving visual tribute, even
though, let's face it: Unown are more than
faintly terrifying.
"They don't care who they zap as long as they
zap!"
In many of the Pokémon games, a common roadblock
is a giant Snorlax sleeping in the middle
of the road.
These giant Pokémon require a special Poké
Flute to awaken them, resulting in the player
going on a quest for the item before being
able to progress to a new area in the game.
Snorlax has also appeared in the Pokémon
anime as well, notably in the episode "Wake
Up Snorlax."
"It's a Snorlax!"
"That's a Snorlax?"
"Alright!"
In that particular episode, a sleeping Snorlax
blocks a water source from flowing into a
nearby town.
Needless to say, Snorlax has been an obstacle
throughout Pokémon, and this trend of Snorlax
inconveniently blocking roads continues in
Detective Pikachu.
In one particular shot after Tim first arrives
in Ryme City, a Snorlax can be seen sleeping
in the road as drivers try to navigate around
it.
While the Snorlax is only shown briefly, its
inclusion is a fun callback that's sure to
appeal to fans.
In an early episode of Pokemon the Series
entitled "Here Comes the Squirtle Squad,"
a group of mischievous Squirtles play pranks
on passersby, going so far as to dig pitfalls
for unsuspecting travelers to fall into.
Eventually, the group of Squirtles come to
see the error of their ways and give up these
wild antics.
"Squirtle, squirtle."
Later on, in the episode "The Fire-ing Squad!,"
the Squirtles diligently work with firefighters
in an official capacity, and even participate
in a firefighting competition.
Squirtles are seen a few times in Detective
Pikachu.
Why, there's one right here on this "missing"
poster.
Elsewhere in the film, we see a group of Squirtles
dutifully working with firefighters from Ryme
City and putting out fires left and right.
We're glad to see they're still out there
fighting the good fight.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.